i was very nervous to tell friends of
mine i was bipolar because i thought
they would think of me differently and
then i told all my friends and nobody
did and it was actually pretty insulting
because i've had friends tell me they
were bipolar and i was like what you
you're kidding and then i told my
friends and they were like dad checks
out that's
comedian taylor tomlinson from look at
you her brand new netflix stand up
special it premieres this coming tuesday
her second netflix showcase all while
still in her 20s as our jamie wax found
out that fast success is something she
celebrates while still aware of the pain
and loss that helped propel it
i remember like doing a show in the
lab when i was maybe like 20 like
definitely before i moved to l.a at 28
taylor tomlinson has reached the heights
of stand-up headlining hallowed rooms
like the main stage of the hollywood
improv this is a big deal this is the
brick wall it's still so crazy to me
that
i've performed here because i think
about like when i moved here this is
like the place you see in interviews
like this like comedians who grow up
watching or you know documentaries or
what have you so you you can't even like
imagine being up here
and like the first night i did a spot
here it i don't even think i was inside
my body i was like oh my god like i'm
one of like i'm actually a comedian now
i had a list when i was eight i tell you
guys that because no one told me
they pulled me aside a year later at
school someone's like taylor your
teacher thinks you might be struggling
with a speech impediment i'm like what's
the speech impediment
but she's also been selling out even
larger venues throughout the country
like here in boston where she takes her
new netflix special look at you hope you
find who you're looking for
if you have any follow-up questions i'll
be on the seashore
it's very cool to walk into this theater
and see
everything set up for a large crowd sold
out crowd all coming to see you what
does that feel like for you i mean it's
incredible it's like what i always
wanted i've never been drunk because i'm
pretty sure i'm an alcoholic
the only times i've ever wanted to drink
are alone and a la quinta inn and i'm
told that's when you're not supposed to
do it
it's the success of her previous special
quarter life crisis which came out a
week before lockdown that has brought
tomlinson such a huge following and so
when we finally got to come back out and
do clubs and then eventually theaters i
was like
blown away by the difference in in
ticket sales where we're like selling
out every weekend at clubs and we're
adding shows in theaters it's a dream
come true not to sound like a disney
princess but her success starts with
humble beginnings in temecula california
where at age 16 she took her first stand
up class in a church basement you really
worked the church circuit for a while
there yeah
yeah that was that was one thing i
learned in that class they were like
don't
don't put out the first number ask what
their budget is
and also to move the mic stand
when you get up there which is huge
that's probably one that's an important
thing everyone should learn if you're
starting stand up is move the mic stand
don't perform behind the mic stand
the comedian learned another lesson when
a joke she tweeted ended her time on the
church circuit i'll have you know in bed
i am a wild animal all right yeah way
more afraid of you than you are of me
she later told that joke on her first
conan appearance they were like we think
you're very funny we can't
have you on tour with us like this is
not on brand for us but we wish you the
best and i remember i was so upset it
just it also just tapped into a lot of
the like religious guilt i felt growing
up and i've spent a lot of years in
therapy trying to untangle it and so
that was the turning point for me i
think i was 22 at the time but in some
way it was a liberation toward what she
really wanted i think it felt like a
liberation
once i got over the initial shame
because i felt a lot of shame after that
phone call
even though logically i knew you know
what this is good the only mental health
advice my dad ever gave me is i was
having panic attacks in high school and
i didn't know what they were that
liberation gave her the freedom to face
issues like her own struggles with
mental health and he goes all right
all i can tell you
is that when you feel like this
get as far away from the people you care
about as possible
not only with refreshing humor but
sometimes with brutal honesty we just
advice you give a werewolf like when i i
watch you tackle this kind of material
that your process really is like if it's
funny it's okay yeah yeah because if
it's if it's not funny it's really it is
just therapy it's just sort of selfish
of me to just go up and be like here are
my feelings in therapy i figured out the
day in my childhood i became an
emotional eater i was eight years old
and i was eating a bagel in the kitchen
and my dad came in and he goes you're
gonna want to put that bagel down i got
to tell you something and that's when he
told me that my mom had died tomlinson
has mined the deepest recesses of her
private experience for comedy and truth
even the loss of her mother at a young
age i went back to fourth grade like the
angel of death everyone's like step on a
crack break your mother's back i'm like
stop eating bread now your mom's dead
dude
did that loss on some level
drive you in any way to be able to to
put yourself out there like that to
strangers yeah
it's look we're all just trying to fill
a hole in here
like this is not i do a joke about it in
the news special where i go do you think
i'd be this successful at my age if i
had a live mom
because i i wouldn't there's just no way
that if
my mom were alive
i would be the same person it is such a
huge part of my identity
and
for me
it helps to contextualize it in that it
helps me to look on the bright side and
go well
it has driven you to work very hard and
it's driven you to try to be
something that she would be proud of i'm
not good at dating because i'm not fun
i'm not like a fun person you could
probably tell that by now for example
this is my impression of a fun person
after years of delivering deeply
confessional material she's ready to put
her current set aside and move to
something perhaps a little lighter i do
think the next hour of material i would
like to be a little lighter
just for my own personal uh mental
health does life feel lighter right now
is that part of what makes you want to
go there
i don't know in so many ways my life is
better
and easier than it ever has been
and then there are certain things that
are
you know mental health-wise still very
difficult and i'm still navigating
and i hope that in two years i will be
in an even better
easier lighter place and my material
will reflect that to give me and my
audience a break i guess
yeah
i love how so matter-of-factly she talks
about her issues um whatever they might
be but she's just like out there and
just letting the cards fall or they may
and
yeah and honest about even you know her
mother what that how that shapes you but
it's helped shape her into
this success that she is and i like what
jamie talks about i mean is there
anything you won't talk about if it's
funny right i will you hear that from a
lot of comedians if it's funny yes
great stuff